erst einmal zurück komischer film waren
wir im letzten fliegt ab veröffentlicht
corona locker und die bewachung der
schweizer grenze zwischen youtube sehr
wirkt viel interesse kann ist und
wieviel rück mal im büro positive
kritische aber faire fragen und sport
über kommentare und fragen hatte weil
sie schon mal mit dem titel corona
lockdown da hängt ja im film selber ist
gar nicht so viel über kronach hoch das
stimmt wir das eigentliche transparent
macht der hintergrund vor dem ganzen
thema ist sich am letzten herbst schon
mal angefangen mit der grenzwächter das
hat mich einfach interessiert was machen
die in der hütte zieht von der offene
grenze war sie im kino tante geschenkt
die nur für sicherheit und der
arbeitstitel vor dem film ist xii
die beschützer der offenen grenzen und
ich wirklich brauche geschäftig sie mit
dem film und genau in dem moment ist
schließlich verordnet weiter von der
grenze aus
die grenzschließung verordnet wurde vom
bundesrat und daher wird das natürlich
gleich welcher bringen
topaktuell ist will er das sind genau
die grenzwacht er jetzt die grenze
geschlossen hängt der himmel ein
aktueller telmex in der garage und aber
möglich weil das bild zeige wie die
grenzwacht erinnerung grenzwacht
schaffen täter fehle ein glück fragt was
ist der unterschied eigentlich zwischen
polizei und grenzwache dass ich das in
grenzach tag fragte im filmischen
täglich also op dieter von kontrolle
noch unbetitelte und alles gleich
kontrollieren waren und so weiter die
grenzwacht in diesem vor allem wenn es
darum geht was grenze überschritt und
läuft also dokumente aus wiesent
kontrolle der soll natürlich und die
migration
die polizei sie hat zum teller
es gibt zwar nur die polizie einzig zum
umsatz rund 6 kriminaltechnik grausamer
mord oder verkehrsunfall dauert das ist
schön es auch vor der polizei vor der
grenzwacht und strukturell die
grenzwacht ischen teil vom hessischen
schulverwaltung und die polizei hätte
diesen vor allem kommt entwickelt und
auf bundesebene ist dass intel vom ejot
pd ja und jetzt frage gehetzt schweiz zu
lange hat die schweiz so lange lockerer
genommen also ein mit sport reagiert
granite filter zu sagen schnitt
unbedingt das thema ob sie vorhin schon
film was für ihn gefragt ob er zur armee
aktiv wird an der grenze also stand
jetzt ist ja so als hätte ein mobiles
jähriger forfour soll dort insgesamt
auch diese quote dass die nun wieder
ohne im einsatz stand aber im moment
sind das vor allem seine tat kompanie
also das sind spital soll dort begrüßt
das wiener spital ganze halver aber was
ich jetzt sagen es ist durchaus denkbar
und das läuft im moment vorbereitet dass
schweizer soldaten erhöhte sich von der
grenze warten mit alpha das wirklich
schockiert also wenig erklärt zeigen
aber das ist nun in dieser nacht
offiziell nachher war selber nur jemand
der mich fragt wenn man der welt schaut
vorbei der grenzpolizei was das
selbermachen den anbieter vor der
eidgenössischen zollverwaltung so viel
wenn ich stress sind immer froh wenn
spiele billiger bekommen dabei ist das
alter informiert
das ist nicht unbedingt termin ist auch
frage sie wieso tragen die schutzmaske
und wenn ich dann gefragt jetzt dass es
gewisse rolle sprecher also das ist
schon heikel fokus im moment scheinen
tim ausgetragen die welt aber sie sagen
dass sie geschaffene kommen sie einfach
was sicher lizenz sind riesige zwei
meter abstand also wenn die zollbeamter
die grenzwächter autos oder so
kontrollieren
der msc meter abstand h was nur frag'
war eine warme regelt jetzt gott sich
und wir machen schluss mit dem abbau
studium füllung sehe dass die hotel
verdächtige ab da stand also die
hinterhand show das ist sicher eine
besondere
das ist einfach gefährlich dass das
eigentlich hätte sie fragen ob sie
zumindest vergangenheit aus russland
korrespondent jemand fragt was wie das
fahrlicht monats xi mit russischen
grenzbeamter also wirklich gerade
stylischen er wurde aber interessante
geschichte sie waren zum ukraine
russland konflikt hat sagt der aktive
kicker von moskau nach kiew darum
eigentlich viel der nachtzug babysitter
und wenn man die obergrenze ist vor der
jetzt natürlich heute control egger und
da sind die bei ungewöhnlich hohen texas
schweizer und auch noch journalist und
erhält sofort in afrika der punkt wo der
hallo wir hinein journalisten des landes
schweizer und der sportliche leiter vom
vom grenzt im dienst ist der fall bei
hohem tempo frage gestellt wo manche was
matthäus weiter und das ist eigentlich
die cerag nahm sibel die hälfte der
bundesbürger hält wisst dass ich jetzt
mit intel wie vor dem zug aber das hat
dazu geführt
weil sich noch mit zither lege eine
pause mache habe sie aber wir haben und
tattoos köln zur glückt und fragt der
eine freundin in der schweiz wie ein
kopfhörer das ist und ich rede nicht mit
alpha es gibt also nur hoffen dass das
andere mal aber es gibt dort nicht vom
bundesrat der show alles ziemlich
detailliert über dem dorf also in der
regel sind also schweizer oder die wir
hier in antholz titelheld oder die war
es grenzgänger grenze oder grenzgänger
dokument endlich einen hohen zuschuss
ziemlich schwierig es gibt ja bewiesen
haben zum beispiel bei beerdigungen oder
so oder eher begrenzt härtefall aber ob
der normale beziehung intel der fall ist
das kann ich zeigen also eine
interessante frage ob sie es geht
eigentlich ein neues top of the city von
der grenze aus
neben schon fall wird filme deutschland
und schweiz oder österreich schweiz
italien schweiz der show frag sie wenn
zum beispiel die tische grenzbehörde
schon jemand kontrollieren ob die
schweizer behörden kontrollieren toben
oder ob man an politik vertrieben
so also jedes land kontrolliert er ist
also die titanic kontrollierter ist und
schweizer die kontrollieren wer
österreichs sondern jeweils werden wäre
er da ist also insofern hits show und
zusammenarbeit aber jedes land noch
selber kontrollieren weil ich jetzt ins
land kommen und fragen ob sie wie
wird lied reagierend also das ist ganz
unterschiedliche level bis jetzt bezahlt
wie sega und dem anfang ist das
natürlich hat das viel für den
vierjährigen verstanden ist gesorgt und
aber chef beklagt dass eine empfehlung
sehe dass das die grenz dass die
abschläge was geht dass die zum fahrer
werden dass themen wie die entwicklung
tue also so viel wenn ich nach wie vor
helikopter und erwachsen grenzgebiet wo
war celtics weltwunder
es ist natürlich nachvollziehen aber
glaubt die grenzen war jeder tag und
geschöpfe hotel oder hilfe ganz wichtige
arbeit machen die in der spittaler im
flughafen zu weiter die hände jetzt zum
teil große umwege für gott schöpfer will
die kleine grenzübergang jetzt völlig
zur sind und dass ein offenes paar
wenige konzentriert und zum teil haben
wir jetzt natürlich 50 kilometer umweg
und das hört dass das hotel für
vierjährige aber was interessant ist das
getränk nicht nur in der stadt sondern
der grenze so gewisse spannungen
zwischen autofahrer und velofahrer und
fussgänger oder zufällig genutzt wurde
dass fussgänger und velofahrer vielfach
aber glänzen kann nicht viel dazu sage
ich glaube das verbot gilt eigentlich
für alle aber wenn die grenze diesen so
lang und wieder ja gott sei dank muss
man sagen die grenzen höhere grenze und
eine andere frau aber vielfach eine maxi
das hat ja schon vor zwei wochen selber
machen
ich glaube da wird man dem schluss
hoffentlich mal bilanz ziehen könnte
jetzt ein viertel der zwischen
politische frage sehen und dazu sagen
dass
die grenzschützer der politisch weil
größter fang abmachung dass das keine
politische kommentare gibt also zum
beispiel ist das gehör durch das
schlecht dass man die grenze schließt
regel je mehr jemand micro von medien
die im studio war der rücktritt hätte
klar
also wir geschafft aber einfach
politische frage sind sind eigentlich
als tabu sie jemand wirft man vor dass
das ideologische aus billige für einen
grenzenlosen globalisierte multikulti
welzig sie also handtaschen auf und cs
geht forsch und im moment kann ich im
grants der grenzwacht in den blick
ob man das gefühl einfach eine delete
hoch schlagen mit der papiere nicht
alles stimmt also es ist mir schon klar
dass man das eigentlich nicht aber es
geht zum thema frage darum die leute mit
der reserve zu holen das ist es ist eine
interessante frage also wenn man peter
migrationsfragen zum beispiel der
familie kindheit war nicht den
schweizern asylbewerber oder verlangen
sondern einfach das land durch welte und
die martini durch laute oder den wir in
den film ein einfacher arbeiter nur
einfach schöner event als bewilligung
abgelaufen
die frau hat man nicht man ist als
grenzwache das gefühl dass man das
eigentlich auch jetzt durch oder aber
unterm strich müsste man schon froh sie
dass das personal hey wo die gesetze
anwenden und die eigentliche durchziehen
aber es ist eigentlich also ja
schließlich nicht in ideologischen
spiele von windows sondern eigentlichen
berechtigte frage ja ich glaube dass das
wahr ist das ist ein großes konzert
aber der fährt nach wie vor fragen
richtig beantworten und wenn das noch
nicht gemacht hätte
doch abonnieren auf dem kanal isaf doch
es sind immer ganz spannende film oder
aktuelle jetzt mein corona bestehen und
blickt und so dass es spannend
bürger und ich hoffe dass wir einander
auf dem kanal wieder sehen